[Applaudissements]
alors année 2007
c'est l'année où steve jobs annonce
l'arrivée du iphone nicolas sarkozy
devient le 23e président de la france le
hashtag est inventé et la fameuse chaîne
de télévision tqs existait encore même
mois en 2010 est tout ce que je me
rappelle c'est que je suis motivé je
suis focus déterminé je performe jeu
culmine je suis en feu je pète le feu
je décide quand même après réflexion que
ça va être ma dernière année en tant
qu'athlète de haut niveau sur l'équipe
canadienne de trampoline et tumbling
ceci est un sport dans les rayons de la
gymnastique mon but c'est de terminer
avec les championnats du monde qui vont
avoir lieu à la fin octobre 2007 puis en
fait que pardon et qui s'envole pour moi
dans la ville de québec et que c'est une
fin parfaite parce que c'est dans notre
province
dénouement incroyable anticipées pour
vous donner une petite idée
trampoline tumbling double mini c'est
les trois disciplines de mon sport en
fait après ça je peux vous dire que ça
déboule en fait tout s'enchaîne avril
je termine 6ème effet la meilleure
performance canadienne en double mini
trampoline à la coupe du monde
mai 2007 le cirque m'invite à faire une
audition personnalisé pour rue leçons du
soleil juin 2007 le même soleil me
propose un contrat pour une nouvelle
création qui auront lieu à macao en
chine
bref mes résultats
mes attentes mes performances mais
acrobaties battent leur plein c'est
l'extase
je vais vous montrer une petite vidéo
qui va en fait vous donner un petit
aperçu de mon sport
[Musique]
il
m
je
[Musique]
voilà comme vous pouvez voir les images
sont très 2007
ces trains peuvent y ait fait juillet
je suis chez moi à la maison je me
baigne je fais des plongeons pour me
délier le corps puis l'homme a mené je
me cogne la tête dans le fond de la
piscine
vraiment rien de grave c'est juste une
de ces journées où ce que je me sens un
peu fatigué of maladroit
bref je le sens pas trop mais il faut
absolument que j'aille m'entraîner parce
que dans deux semaines c'est la coupe
c'est la canada cup en fait qu'est la
dernière qualification pour les
championnats du monde par le mois je
m'en vais m'entraîner je me change
femmes et acrobaties promener je dévie
un peu puis j'étais obligé d'écarter les
jambes pour éviter la barre de métal de
l'appareil ce qui fait que je perds de
vue ma jambe une fraction de seconde
résultat mega entorse de la cheville
en fait j'ai comme senti mon tibia qui
voulaient sortir épices fracassés comme
une espèce de ben e un come back qui
peut arriver
chanceux dans ma malchance je le sais
pas mais pour moi tout ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que c'est la fin du
monde
avec le recul j'ai comme le flash
continuelle de moi qui se baignent
puiqu'il sans peau je me suis pas écouté
j'ai forcé la note
et voilà les jours passent puis en fait
c'est pire que je pensait définitivement
votre canada cup et je suis obligé de
renoncer également à un camp
d'entraînement en france une compétition
en grande bretagne une coupe du monde en
russie et les dix championnats du monde
je suis des goûts p c'est comme si mon
corps avait décidé de prendre sa
retraite trois mois trop tôt
l'importance de vraiment relier sa tête
son corps et son coeur début septembre
je reçois un appel à l'eau david c'est
gymnastique canada avec les résultats
antérieurs on a décidé de remettre quand
même sur l'équipe nationale pour les
mondiaux what moi c'est comme voir la
bonne nouvelle
myhrer d'espoir
mais relève retroussent les manches
m'entraîne à fond ça va bien 18 octobre
2010 est précisément une semaine avant
les championnats du monde je cours à
pleine vitesse juste avant de percuter
la toile du trampoline pilote c'est ma
cheville gauche qui abdique compensation
totale
je passais de l'étole 100% foule pin à 0
en une nanoseconde
c'était une bouillie mon affaire j'ai
jamais connu quelque chose d'aussi
violent jeu comme blanc comme un droit
j'ai des sueurs froides qui me colle
partout qui se mélange à mes larmes
tugud salé diagnostique entorse qui le
niveau 14
je pense de la cheville gauche j'exagère
mais c'est juste pour vous dire à quel
point il me reste plus beaucoup de
ligaments la preuve ces quelques jours
après factice a évolué exit les
championnats du monde et aussi le sceau
du soleil m'appelle mêmes formes que vu
que je pourrais pas commencer à temps
ben mon contrat est à présent sur la
glace
deva site est confus en colère contre
cette injustice le impuissant face à la
situation que je sais très bien que
c'est arrivé
aucune potion magique aucune machine à
retourner dans le temps va pouvoir
régler mon malheur ça que j'ai comme
terminer ma carrière de compétition en
queue de poisson qui en voyant tous mes
rêves tangible à un mètre de moi
s'écrouler j'ai cuvée ma peine pendant
des mois dans le sol de chez mes parents
dépressif les deux pieds dans des bacs
de glace à faire la physio trois fois
par semaine au moins un minimum
thiam frotter tous les produits
inimaginable de l'argile verte des
crèmes chinoise des injections
homéopathiques et j'en passe pourquoi je
vous raconte ça parce que ça m'a
tellement rentrer dedans
malgré tous les beaux adage david
à quelque chose malheur est bon ils n'y
arrivent jamais rien pour rien dans la
vie
j'ai vraiment eu de la difficulté à me
résoudre à me résoudre que toutes ces
années de travail d'acharnement de
pleurs de sueur se sont aussi consolidé
comme ça jusqu'à ce que je réalise en
fait que les échecs et nous change pour
le mieux quand on y porte attention que
ce fameux l'automne 2007 super intense
c'était la route en fait vers mon point
de rupture
l'élément déclencheur qui allait faire
en sorte que j'allais devenir une
meilleure personne
après ça tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que je me sens très vraiment sûr
exclusivement je pourrai désormais les
accomplissements et réussit résultats
médaille
applaudissements si j'avais pas une
reconnaissance immédiate
il ya comme un vide qui se créent à
l'intérieur de moi si j'échoue est à mes
yeux j'étais nul mais sur toute la ligne
c'est dans toutes les sphères de ma vie
alors que dans le fond c'est
circonstancielle ça dure pas je
compétitionne une journée je rate tout
je pourrai refaire la même compétition
le lendemain que je réussirai tout est
ce que je suis nulle pour autant basée
sur un seul jour de différence
j'ose croire que non on est tellement
plus qu'une seule dimension tellement
plus que juste notre enveloppe
corporelle
j'ai commencé à comprendre
il fallait que je dis ceci dit j'étais
de ce que j'accomplissais j'ai commencé
aussi à m'écouter davantage suis mon
intuition me connaître un peu mieux j'ai
aussi développé une meilleure
sensibilité une plus grande résilience
un changement du mot importé parce que
si on veut vraiment faire des
changements aussi dans le monde changer
les choses il faut aussi être ouvert à
se changer soi même osé prendre des
risques affronter les obstacles est
aussi acceptée d'échouer à l'occasion
par tout ce processus là m'a amené à me
questionner questionné sur ce que je
voulais faire devenir et à être qui bat
jean jouve régime et ce rapidement ma
conclusion est je voulais à fait me
démarquer et faire les choses
différemment
le ramener j'ai eu un mcdo flash dans un
restaurant en ontario
j'ai comme la mabilais recommandé la
caisse de biens ils ont comme fait
rouler sur un convoyeur
pas de tapis juste les tuyaux
cylindrique métalliques
je me suis dit ah ça serait cool avons
une espèce de roues qui retombe sur
elle-même la tuque qui restent sur place
qui moi je ferai des acrobaties à
travers ça j'ai cogité j'ai fait des
plans des croquis pour au final tout
laissé seul dans le fond de ma
garde-robe
c'est juste des années plus tard que
j'ai déterré tout ça j'ai construit mon
propos mon prototype pardon de surco
ceux ci le nom justement de mon
invention qui est un appareil
acrobatique unique au monde je les ai
inventés avec l'aide de mon ami joël en
fait qui lui est tellement comme
intelligent emmanuel sans mentir j'ai
peut-être fait 10% qu'il y ait fait tout
le reste
si je m'en cogne occuper 10 heures
j'avais trop peur que ça a l'air de
l'armorique et/ou d'une cafetière
électrique c'était parce que ce que je
recherchais on a fait tout ça sans plan
avec les connaissances qu'on avait il ya
fait une super job mais des embûches
c'est sûr que j'en ai connu les morceaux
qui tombe avec la force de l'impact la
rotation qui meurent parce que ça frotte
contre les parois le temps à mon idée
originale au beer store qui la
concrétisation matériel ou encore moi
qui connais en foot parce que je me
pensais bonbons avec un grain de fait
que pardon fax et ça avec moi qu'est ce
que je peux vous dire de quelle est la
morale de cette histoire pour être
créatif buvait de la bière non
sans blague je pensais de suivre
davantage son intuition
puis c'est tellement difficile
aujourd'hui parce qu'elle est enseveli
de bruit de stimuli de technologie faut
vraiment cultiver son silence intérieur
puis d'écouter la petite voix qui nous
habite
parce que aussi on est porté à avoir
seulement des fois le résultat final
puis je m'inclus tellement là dedans on
oublie t par contre on des fois c'est un
piège en fait pour moi des fois ce soit
qu'on pense que c'est facile ou soi que
c'est inatteignable
c'est dangereux moi je pense que on
oublie des fois tout ce qui est le
bahreïn de things les tentatives les
essais les petites réussites les échecs
qui sont pour moi un passage obligé
c'est comme ça qu'on en ressort plus
transformé grandi puisque une image vaut
mille mots
e
mon
[Musique]
alors ce que je peux vous dire c'est la
construction de ce recueil mon appareil
ça reflète en quelque sorte ma propre
reconstruction personnelle
tous les obstacles de ma dernière moitié
d'année 2010 est en fait c'est c'est ce
qui m'a permis d'apprendre que je
pouvais passer au travers mais peu
importe ce qui arrive et que j'allais
avoir plus d'outils que j'allais me
forger une personnalité encore plus
ancré inquiétez vous pas fait suis loin
d'être parfait je continue de manger
encore débat
aujourd'hui je savais que les images
qu'on a visionné je me suis ramassé deux
fois l'hôpital
si bien over pied fracturé juste pour
vous dire il faut donc pas voir les
obstacles comme quelque chose à éviter
absolument ou qui fait changer le cours
de notre route
des fois les obstacles il faut les
enjamber sauter par-dessus foncé
continuer est ce que j'ai perdu espoir
souvent ce que j'ai été découragé
énormément parce que je doute encore
beaucoup mais ça fait partie du
processus
je vous montrais mes dernières images
qui pour moi mais d'avant l'ativité tout
le chemin parcouru que les difficultés
rencontrées
mais surmonter enfui en fait amplifie
mon sentiment de fierté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
comment ça
mais m
10 heures
c
honda
à
comment
weatherbug
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je dirais persévérer vous avez
tellement en être récompensé que ce soit
par les efforts fournis le résultat
final la personne que vous allez devenir
être ou jackpot
les trois en même temps je vous dirais
rester créatif vulnérables rêveur ça
importe tellement puis d'être combatif
déterminé ouvert c'est comme ça qu'on
peut apporter des vrais changements en
soi même mais aussi à l'externe
merci david girard
[Applaudissements]